Oh,
why are you on the right side now?
It's a game that was sent to me from my parents' house, but if you don't mind,
genmaicha has less caffeine and a nice aroma, so I think it helps me relax
a
[music]
] Don't get kicked, let's do our best tomorrow
Thank you,
you're pretty hungry, aren't you?
That doesn't mean everyone is thanking Kiri for the study session,
right?
Just doing what I want to do, and I'm pasting it I
'm going through the thickets
[Music]
I'm starting to want to eat something, how much do you want to eat
?  I
wonder if you really don't have the feeling of admiring a sealed dragon
.
I used to change my mind just by seeing your face, but
now I don't mind it so much